afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
psycheck your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel
um I just thought I would go live I've
promised you guys I would try to do this
a little bit more often and we can talk
a little bit about Stargate you can ask
the questions you can decide what we're
going to talk about
so
we'll get into it
[Music]
it's been a bit of an interesting week
actually we've had a couple of bits and
Bob's drop
first of all we are going to talk about
the podcast Brothers video that went on
because I've had a few questions about
that we'll have a little bit of a chat
about timekeepers and we'll have a
little bit of chat about these SGU
rumors and what do we think
um they mean if anything I'm leaning
towards they mean nothing but we'll have
a chat about it and we'll see what you
guys think as well let's just have a
look who's in popcorn Pro Zoom
jordanator how you doing Batman the
gator very nice Jonah good evening Jay
and good evening Jordy so my son's
name's Jordy just decide a bit of
Interest Andrew howdy sir how are you
diddling right so first of all the
podcast Brothers Kerry Davey B
everybody's in the house and the podcast
Brothers video
um I assume you guys are a lot of you
guys if you Gators big fans will have
seen it um it's the first
um uh everyone's in Simone Laura Me
nails fortex Howies if anybody's got any
questions ah
oh that's not true we're quite nasal but
anyway
um Bobby's in see here see what's up uh
the sky
um sorry uh so the podcast Brother video
so
um I've had a few questions about what
in the video did I agree with what in
the group of video didn't I agree with
there's a couple of things in there that
I I don't think are quite right but
mostly on the whole the guys
um did uh Jess how you doing Dave
evening
and the guys did the video that pretty
much
covered everything we've been talking
about in the last six months
so
um this target was going to get
announced at sdcc at the San Diego Comic
Con the um podcast guy said their Source
had actually seen the
um teaser video that they're going to
put up they said it was going to pan
across the San Francisco bridge and then
it was going to go underwater and we
were going to see the gate dialing up
and um and that was going to be the the
start of that of that you know that
little teaser
um I've not heard that I've not seen
this teaser I did see a little snippet
thanks to one of my sources about
um some promotional work they did about
six months ago
um but that was
um when they were still thinking about
announcing this back in January and it
was it sounded similar to be fair it
started on San Francisco
but it didn't then go under the water
stuff so I don't know about that uh
alien world how are you doing
[Music]
um so I I don't know about that intro
sequence they mentioned
um my understanding is they decided they
weren't going to be
um announcing a San Diego Comic-Con as
early as maybe March or April they sort
of realized
um
the the actors are going to go on strike
chances are they were pausing and
waiting because the directors
agreed a deal so then there was a little
bit of
um confidence maybe they're thinking
right if the directors have agreed a
deal that kind of takes a lot of the
window the sales of the writers
so maybe the actors won't go on strike
but then it went on and on and on and
obviously very became clear that the
actors were going to go on strike and it
was agreed they weren't going to
announce anything
um thing but I've only found out the
last like two weeks actually they about
six weeks ago or maybe even as much as
two months ago they decided they weren't
going to announce the San Diego
Comic-Con
um
another thing they mentioned was that
there's no David blue has been
approached to play Eli
um we're going to talk about the SGU
room is a little bit later but I 100
agree with the propcast guys on that one
as well as I've been told a few times
now that David blue has not been
approached informally or formally about
anything and in fact that Amazon don't
want to
now I have been told a couple of rumors
about why that is but I don't think it's
fair to share
um because really
you know track Gate's got a good point
there Futurama keeps going backwards and
forwards and it keeps coming back
as Harris will tell you it's his
favorite Sci-Fi show ever made though
top of top of his list best sci-fi show
ever made
idiot
Amanda Tapping right so
it's a good go away from podcast for two
seconds the rumor I heard
God
must be eight nine months ago
was that actually Amazon had already
talked to Amanda Tapping about
potentially
um coming back and maybe directing and
everything with the star game
um my understanding is she signed an NDA
she's not allowed to talk about it but
she is aware that there are certain
plans there was also a conversation
apparently about her maybe come back as
an executive producer or something like
that which because that's work she does
with other things so
yes basically it's very very possible
the man typing could because
one thing Amazon are very very concerned
about
is that
there's
um it's the rings of power problem that
we've talked about loads of times on the
channel and they don't want any negative
any negative YouTubers aren't you know I
don't do that but any that nonsense that
came with rings of power and lots of
other shows those hate clickers they
don't want to do that and one of the
ways they can do it this is how
Executives think is get something like a
man to tap into direct or Show run or
get to produce or something like that
because it immediately takes a lot of
the you know the emphasis away from the
hate clickers to go on new people knew
this knew that no Brad right if you do
that it really helps so I think there's
a very very good chance of anti-tapping
could be involved heavily in this
um
I mean there's nothing stuck in Amazon
that we know of
there's nothing stopping Amazon
announcing this right now it could
literally come tomorrow
if they
my understanding is again they have a
director
informally
they have a lot of development work done
informally they potentially have a
script
um there's lots of things that are lined
up
what they don't want to do is make
themselves look like an evil
big Studio that doesn't care about the
writers and the directors and everything
so while the strike's going on I think
it's unlikely just because it would be a
bit of a PR problem
um but there is actually nothing now and
as if the director
signed a deal tomorrow I think we'd know
within about a week I think I think we'd
know quite quickly if they actually got
the director to agree because then
you're starting to actually lock stuff
in and it starts to become a lot more
difficult to to keep a lid on it
lots of leaks have come out from Amazon
obviously but if deadline or variety
start actually getting leaks that they
can verify and the story comes out then
obviously the cat's out the back we're
going to talk about the deadline story
in a second as well
um doesn't make sense to the teaser to
pan under San Francisco gate dialing
collect no I I don't understand why it's
underwater why there's a gate underwater
unless that's something to do with the
storyline obviously that we don't know
so that could be something interesting
or it could just be that they thought it
was a funky
shot I don't know
um
yeah and I think the only thing that
worries me about the development work
and the pause this now put on Stargate
is that it does give people time to
think about stuff into Executives to get
involved and start thinking about stuff
and what the one of the things they
might do is start thinking that maybe
they could do it cheaper and we don't
want that we don't want them thinking
man we want them doing
but I do think there's a lot of
development work going on I've got a
video coming actually about Brad
Wright's way of setting up TV shows and
things that we'll that'll be on in a
week or two
um
and setting up the rules and set another
planet and actually the planning stage
is very very important if you want to
notice coherent sci-fi show
so I do think that's going to be really
important
um
it's
it's difficult Alienware stuffcast is
Jason mode done with scargary could he
pull some strings
I've only ever seen him speak in
interviews with my Stargate a couple of
times and he's always really positive
about it he always seems that like
that's what started his career with
Stargate Atlantis and it's a character
that he really enjoyed playing
we've said it a million times didn't we
if you're going to do a Stargate movie
that's actually going to succeed
get Jason Momoa to come back as Ronan
and do a do a run a movie
you can actually it actually would be a
sneaky way of setting up a lot of things
as well because whatever he's running
from or whatever problems have been
caused that's a sneaky way of like
telling us a lot of what happened over
the last 10 years 15 years
so I think when I sort of write that
story in my head
it solves a lot of problems doing film
like that and also but you can keep it
as like an action movie it can be quite
simple basic plot of him running from a
provided I've always got some sort of
problem he's having to you know fight
against with his with his Magnums
um but it it allows you to have a lot of
stuff going on in the background which
tells us a lot of things
um
Ronin movie
defending the planet yeah 100 I agree
with it I think that should be a
no-brainer it's whether they get to do
them getting to do it and whether Amazon
are willing to pay because at the moment
we've heard rumors again that the budget
is looking at about 70 million dollars
for sci-fi straight to cinema movie
that's not a massive budget now that's
an initial working budget it could
become more than that
but
[Music]
Jason Momo is probably going to want to
Best Best Buy 20 million to do it
unless you give him
um a smaller fee say maybe five million
given to produce the role and then give
him a back end like they did with Robert
Downey Jr when they got him to do Iron
Man
that's a way of doing it you know giving
one percent of the growth afterwards
you'd probably go for that because if
filmed as well it could make a lot of
money
um that's
that's one way I think
I I I if you look at actors a lot of the
actors of age you know they're a bit
older
um obviously Richard Dean Anderson is is
a lot he's in his 70s
um but a lot of the actors look great
Joe Flanagan looks great Amanda Tapping
looks great Michael Shanks looks great
um you know on and on and on to be
honest none of these actors
maybe Richard Dean Anderson but to be
honest he still looks pretty good he's
lost a load of weight and he's looking
pretty good I would say none of these
actors
you can signal out sort of thing all of
them should return
um
I think all of them could return in
little bits and if they don't get
um David Hewlett back in I don't know
what the hell is going on
but right the sort of podcasts thing so
they basically said that there's gonna
be no David blue to return now they've
took that to mean that that means
there's going to be no SGU conclusion
we'll talk about the SGU animated movie
in in a bit but I think if I'm if I'm
honest I don't think there will be an
SGU conclusion immediately I think that
will come much later
um I don't think they'd have approached
David blue now anyway but I think the
podcast guys here are sort of
insinuating what I've been told again is
that
they don't want to approach him and I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna say any more
than that because it's stuff I don't I
don't really know who understands if
it's true or not
um but apparently there are some there
are some issues there
so even if David blue
even if they did do an SGU something
David blue may not appear in it so
um now I don't think that that
necessarily means there won't be an SGU
thing I don't think that means well the
SGU animated movie rumor isn't true
because you either Eli's either dead
he's the one that was awake there could
be a disaster he didn't survive
and then the pods open and Russian
people come out
if they do an animated movie they can
just get somebody else to voice his role
if they really really don't want David
blue involved whatever reason and you
know
um
I've already put the video up what did
you say Vortex on the content but what
about I'd love to know what you uh what
your comment was
um
yeah RDA was great after season five
yeah he was he's not like he's white now
long hair still he's got wire than me
um
so do you think it's season six of
Atlantis can be produced instead of a
new series
no if I'm honest probably not
um I think Atlantis will be in the
series movies or something at some point
but I don't think they will revive
um SG or SGA I think even when we get a
Revival of sg1 which is the rumor that
I've heard repeatedly that that's the
kind of thing they want to do it won't
be straight to Revival as in all of
every all the actors come back and it's
all exactly the same it'll be like
that style of show but you can argue
that SGA was very much similar in sg1 in
lots of ways and style
um so I don't think they'll just do a
straight up
you know that that would be something
Gators would love but the the executives
aren't thinking about just what we love
they're not just thinking about those
gators they're thinking about all the
new people they want to bring into it as
well and all the new audience they want
to generate so no if I'm honest they
could but they won't
[Music]
um
I think SGU completely out it wouldn't
make sense
um
I I agree with you after in lots of ways
this is my one problem I say we'll talk
about the SGU rumors for the animated
movie now instead of later we'll talk
about it now
I said in the video when I talk about
that because I got to share this
information from the source that I know
works at MGM I don't talk to them very
often
um but they just came to me with this
message going well how did you know that
they're doing an SGU movie animated
movie and I said I didn't it was just
that was just me thinking out loud I
thought it was logical and then but I
didn't get much more information out of
them than that
so I'm
so I've put that information out there
she has suggested that there are yes
there is an animated movie and it's
already in production
I don't know any more than that
so but but I have to admit I doubt
that's true I don't think it's true I I
think it's more likely I don't think
she's lying but I think it's more likely
there's been conversations they've and
she's
put two and two together and got six I
think that's more likely I think this I
think this rumor will be at least partly
true is what I'm saying but I think in
production
when all the strikes are coming up and
everything though Amazon might have
thought look we want to get something
out
let's how about we just do an animated
movie we can get it smashed six months
so we can get it done and we can we can
have it we can release it within within
within the 12 months we could have it
done not long after the strikes are done
we could have it released so I think it
is genuinely possible that they're doing
in that SGU animated movie I think it's
possible that it could already be in
production
um I just think it's unlikely
but in lots of ways it makes sense
because it would be much cheaper to
produce they they produce these things
for about four to five million dollars
Warner Brothers
um these Batman moves and things have
been doing for years they always use the
same technology you just use the same
animators they're not setting up
anything new they're just redoing it so
you know they're quite cheap to produce
they're quite quick to produce one of us
have got good at it
um The Babylon Five movie that we've got
to come out the I believe the budget was
six million so it's nothing compared to
live action you know a live action t or
even one episode of something live
action would probably cost 10 million
um and that's just for one hour sort of
things they can they can do a two-hour
movie for that and they can do a quick
one
so but I don't think it makes sense when
you're thinking about trying to then
bring in a big wider audience
because
that's really a Gators thing you need to
have watched SGU for it to make sense
now an animated movie they could do as a
as to get but basically focus it at us
The Babylon 5 movie is aimed around
they're not doing that to create new
Babylon 5 fans they've made that four
Babylon 5 fans SGU animated movie could
be made for us as an intro into
everything else
but it was if it is true I can say to
you it was never the plan that's never
it was it was never been discussed
before as far as I know none of the
other sources I've ever spoken to know
anything about it it was never the plan
to do an SGU animated movie first if
it's true
it's if it happens it's because of the
strikes basically they've they've done
it because the strikes can happen
um
biggest mystery we can't ignore that
yeah but it would as I say though it
would be simply for SGU fans
that's why I think an animated movie is
more likely we'd love to see a third
season at SGU I'd love to see it the
soul Show's getting good it deserves it
but from a business point of view it
makes no sense it just doesn't make any
sense to do it
um
as general turnovers to you SGU does
deserve the conclusion and that's why I
think it would be a really nice way to
start the new franchise with getting us
back to what we had before
and finishing all that off
tiny nice bow on the first phase of the
Stargate franchise and kicking off the
new franchise so what do I think the
animated me but that's why
that's why I thought the animated movie
that's why I came up with the idea of
the animated movie because I thought it
was logical
so would it shock me that an executive
has thought the same thing as me that
this would be a logical way to do this
well no that's why it's that's why it's
maybe possible
about doing that video though because it
is speculation there's a lot of
speculation there's a lot of information
about that rumor I don't know
and it has and a few people have got
quite annoyed about that video because
it's because it's speculation and I
understand that
what I decided was though that at the
end of the day if I didn't do that video
and then in six months time they
announced that there's an SGU animated
movie and I sit here and go I knew that
back in in July
I'd have been either been yeah right
whatever so that's why I decided to
start up I'm just going to do it and
talk about it but um
yeah the formula for a successful reboot
is definitely more in line with what
Atlantis did I mean just do it for
today's audience I wouldn't disagree
with that
yeah
private investigator he's got nothing
else to do
um
Nostalgia does sell particularly at the
moment Nostalgia is very popular look
and then they Picard season three was
just one big Nostalgia Fest
and um and it was very and Trek he's got
very excited because of it but I haven't
watched it since and it's not so good
second time around once they're
Nostalgia wears off
and we do want something that's got to
be something new but at the end of the
day the Stargate sg1 formula is
effective it's like the original Star
Trek formula ship explore boom TNG
basically had exactly the same formula
modernized it you know put a slightly
different spin on it different
characters obviously and it was
massively successful but they kept the
basic original formula
that's what I'm hoping they're going to
do with Stargate is that we're going to
get that basic formula of sg1 teams
going through the gate exploring monster
of the week stuff as well as that
overarching storylines a book keep it
reasonably simple and don't get try and
get picked up try and be too clever with
it we've got Stargate formula that works
do that you know um but do it in a new
way do it in with new stories new
characters new everything else
um
Quantum Leap kind of did it was kind of
a continuation
so it was a soft rebooting that it's new
character's name for him but
um it depends what you mean by Soft
ebook because people argue about that
but in lots of ways it was a
continuation also is a new series
um
let's have a look what's people saying
appeal to the greater audience Stargate
Barbie will cross over make the Barbie
world a new one
world
so
let's just have a look through the thing
as a Jamie in the house hey Jamie good
name strong name you spelled it wrongly
the eyes in the wrong place
until a few years ago I never had to
spell my name
right so I I like a political j or or
you know um or Jim sometimes my dad
calls me Gene
um but um
until about 10 years ago Jamie yes
j-a-m-i-e and then all of a sudden that
I started wandering around
I've seen some people spell it with two
eyes it's crazy
um but I would love to see the discovery
of friendly ancient replicators emulate
an ancient life and culture become
allies another forgotten ancient
experiment hello closet living breathing
agents
why not
wouldn't be very exciting though they'd
have to like
something would have to go wrong
somewhere and yeah it would be very much
in the vein of like the Castlevania the
Batman movies unless you the Babylon 5
movie I think if we if this if this
rumor is true and I'm saying I'd like to
say I would I wouldn't put money on it
I wouldn't give you good odds on it so
don't don't think I'm really supporting
this rumor because I'm not
um but it'll it'll look like movie if it
comes out it'll it'll look like
Castlevania
um or maybe a bit more more like the
Babylon 5 movie was with a little bit
more computer generated and because
they're going to use the same software
the same artists Etc as they're doing
for Bible five maybe if it's true
so it will look like that
I know you can't talk about the stuff
you know but can you write your secret
on a scale of one to ten right so
crowbar here was talking about something
I mentioned on a live the other day and
I know there is something I know about
the Stargate plans that I can't mention
because the source that is told at me is
right next to it basically if if I was
to tell you the details of this
um it would
put his job at risk simple as that so
yeah so I've not been told but I am very
excited I do want to say it and I keep
letting it slip out and I shouldn't it's
me and I'm really sorry about this guys
but I would give it a good
it's a good solid seven out of ten it's
not like
you know Richard Dean Anderson is coming
back and he's going to be sure you know
it's not like something like amazing or
um you know the entire cast is back and
it's not it's not quite that thing but
it's it's really good
and when it gets announced
or if someone else leaks it I really
hope the podcast guys had this
start talking on this and then when
before the video came out because
obviously knew it was coming out and I
was just like I think I might know what
you know because they were they were
really beefing this this video what like
saying this is new exclusive information
and I've disagreed on that there was
nothing new nothing exclusive
um in the video particularly other than
maybe the tea is a bit
but um so I thought I actually messaged
him and sort of was having a chat with
him about it and then I actually said I
think I know what you've got and if it's
got I really really hope this what
you've got because then I can say it
um but they didn't they didn't have it
so
um
fingers crossed
either I can get permission or
um it'll come out but yeah so it's a
good seven or eight hour turn it's it's
it's good you'll like it
um I know people hate I I just think
with the animation thing mate at the
moment the option is it's either an
animated movie or nothing if the
animated movie is being done we can get
that
we couldn't get it this year or early
next year it could be released
um if if it's live action we're probably
looking at two years now until we get
anything actual a movie anything other
screens at the cinema so I just think
it's again this is maybe just me being
logical maybe being a bit overly hopeful
but because it can be done so quickly
and because it can be done really things
you know if the if the strikes go until
January which some people say they might
we could then get the Stargate announced
and say February but we get how about
you get to start getting announcements
and they're saying oh by the way
um April 1st April 1st we're going to be
releasing a start getting SGU animated
movie
it's going to be coming in within eight
weeks animated movie is going to drop
we would go nuts and what a way to
announce Stargate you know people would
talk about that
so again it's a logical thing for them I
think they might have done but
um
sdu animated move to the Gators up and
push the algorithm on Prime to expose
more people starting
and that's what it's about
that is what it's about it's about
those algorithms it's about those things
it's about getting people to watch the
damn show and at the moment
there's a lot of excitement out there
we're going to talk about the
timekeepers game at the moment there's a
reason why it's been delayed till now
it's not just they've had some
development issues which they've had
they've had some storyline issues we'll
shall explain as well but the main
reason is they don't want to release it
until people actually buy it
they need a lot of hype about Stargate
and the hype that's been coming so go
back to this then
um they did talk about in the podcast
video that the movie is still the main
plan we know that we've been talking
about for a long time since uh November
or December or something we've been
talking about that
the one thing I do disagree with them
and I've told them I disagree with them
on this is that they said the deadline
story was it March April a couple of
months ago anyway it was a non-story
didn't mean anything people all got
excited I got excited about it but it
didn't mean anything in the deadline
story it said RoboCop
um you know legally born three that's
the one we're excited for you know it is
um and Stargate probably a movie they
put probably in the actual in the
storyline because we know because we've
been talking about it for months and
Jenny stiven have been talking about it
on and dial the gay actually as well but
we know that's because there's a lot of
infighting between MGM and Amazon at the
moment and one group want to do a series
the other group wants to do a movie
Jennifer salkey's in charge though so it
looks like we're getting a movie but
because that conversation was still
going on they threw in the probably word
now
I think that is really really important
because that's actually Amazon talking
to deadline now the podcast guy
suggested that actually it was deadliner
just watched their video and then told
us about it and that's where they got
the information from and I'm like
deadline don't do that deadline don't
get information from YouTube videos
they're not watching me they actually
talk to Executives Etc at think they can
actually talk to people formally
that information came from Amazon
that's why we can be excited about it
that's why it was really an important
story so that's the only thing really in
the podcast video I Really disagree with
them about I have said them I disagree
with them on that
um
if I mean you can argue that okay maybe
they're listening to my videos in that
case the the
um the story should have come out last
last bloody September
um because that's when we told you guys
so you know I don't I don't think that's
how that works and that's why it's so
important that
um
you know that that story came out
because that was I as far as I'm
concerned the first confirmation form
link that we've had I can I hear loads
and loads of rumors
but
yeah
um Vortex you're right from business
perspective it wouldn't make any
business to bring this to you first I
agree with that I wouldn't start with
SGU It's like Star Trek one step after
the other but fast and like I said the
original plan as far as I know was to
start with a movie come back with a
series and then at some point down the
line I have heard that they would like
to resolve the SGU problem Brad Wright
wanted to do it
um when he was setting this up and I
think it would make sense but it makes
sense further down the line get the show
established get it up and running get a
few people watching it and then give
something to the Gators a bit later that
is the way they do now I've heard that
that was that is the plan that's what
I've heard of from many sources over the
last 18 months that is the plan
I do think though the only thing that's
maybe like say the joke in the pack is
the strikes
and if this room is true that'll be why
that's why we'll get it won't be because
it was ever the plan it'll be because
the strikes just made it make sense and
it'll be simple as that
um
we all know sdu will end up that Rush
Eli create the Universe I think go back
in time and they cause the big Bank
uh you can always tell a lot of TV shows
when they don't have a plan and I don't
think Brad Wright does this for a second
because he meticulously plans ahead
but
um you can tell TV shows sometimes like
manifest and um and lost and things like
that when they paint themselves into a
corner and they don't know where to go
next so what they do is they basically
have to say God did it
um and I always wonder if SGU was gonna
go that way but I think they would have
had a plan for it
um
we need to merge all three TV shows into
one somehow I honestly think that is the
plan
we're going to see all elements of
definitely from sg1 industry Atlantis
anyway we're going to see that
um I think we'll see The Wider Stargate
Universe I I will not be surprised if we
see the wraiths again because that's
again if you're talking about SGU not
being concluded SG Atlantis wasn't
either there were plans there for a
movie that was supposed to wrap all that
up The Wraith is still out there
I do think we're going to see them again
and the city ships
it's it's probably Atlantis is probably
the Earth's most valuable piece of
technology or you know you know resource
so we're going to see it again it would
make no sense otherwise if we didn't see
it again
so yeah I think that we're going to see
bits of everything and then I think SGU
will be concluded at some point and that
will be brought into it maybe one of the
two of the characters will be brought
into it not David blue apparently
um
generally would actually prefer it to be
left alone
than animated now I don't agree with you
there on Jamie on that one
um
I I honestly think I'd rather have that
than nothing
I would rather have that than listen I
won't love it as much as live action I'm
with you on that I don't like animates
as much as live action but the Babylon 5
animated movie I'm genuinely excited
about and that is something we would not
have got otherwise it's an animated
story yeah okay
um it's for Babylon 5 fans it's not made
for kids
brilliant
um but it's just but it won't be as good
as if they'd have done a live action
movie just one
but it's better than nothing I'd rather
I honestly I'd rather have that it's
amazing when the musical comes I am not
dancing
I sing occasionally I can't help myself
with singing occasionally but I'm not
dancing
no
um
so yeah um so on the whole if you're
wondering whether the podcast video is
legit
I can tell you as well that they've told
me that their source is close to the
project so I asked around for a couple
of people that I know that are close to
the project and none of them have said
they are anything to do with podcasts
they've never heard of these guys have
not spoken to them so it's a different
source that they've got and I don't
speak to everybody involved I speak to
one or two people I've got I know two
people that are reasonably close to
what's going on
um
and they're they're more of the business
side of things so they're they're the
people telling me that they're looking
we're pretty sure there's a director
involved oh we're pretty sure the studio
space is going to be used blah blah
things like that
um
this person that they speak to is maybe
more creative side and I've not got as
much access to that
so but the one thing I really like is
that they've got virtually identical
information to me
um a slightly different perspective on a
few things but that's fine that's great
because it gives us a bit more I've
always said to you guys I don't see the
full picture I see Snippets of
information I get bits of information
and then we try to piece that together
and then over time sometimes we go that
makes sense now
we thought it was this but no no it's
like that but you know what I mean it's
and so we try to piece that together so
this is just a little bit more
information for us
that we can then build on
um
yeah I think it's it's it's it's really
good that they've done this video
um so yeah they mostly agree with what
we're saying they mostly agree we watch
any stiven saying
um the who you know appears on gate cast
I think I think she'll be okay with me
saying that um we might be having Jenny
stiven come to speak to us at some point
very shortly and we'll see when not 100
yeah but we're crossing our fingers
um and yeah I just think it would be
really interesting it is really
interesting I should say that they've
come out with some of the similar
information
um
they don't particularly watch my channel
I know they they I think they subscribe
I think that you know well I see them
comment occasionally but
um I watch their stuff I talk to them on
lives I talk to them through Twitter but
they don't necessarily and I think
they're the same as me I don't
particularly want to watch
or the channels particularly because I
think it then models my thinking I like
to just do what I do I talk to the
people I speak to and I do what I do
um and I think they're probably the same
they don't want to to get information
with us because it confuses you think
and if you start listening to everyone
else's so
um are you interested in Stargate time
Keepers yes I have we could talk about
it very quickly it's been delayed by
um two years it was supposed to come out
two years ago
now Slytherin State there's been a load
of story issues delaying it
um it's going to be made up of basically
two parts that you buy together but it's
like two bits there's 14 episodes
they're called animal missions it starts
off um after the aftermath of the
Antarctica battle within sg1
um and the creators said it's very much
going to be in the vein of sg1 but it
does jump through time
now I was told
a long time ago that Amazon were very
keen for this game to be drawn into the
bigger universe that they're then hoping
to create with the new Star game
franchise
on them it's all that that is why this
game has been delayed so much because
Amazon asked them to make some quite big
changes to the game to make it fit with
what they're planning to do later now
this game is still we still don't
actually have a release date the beta is
about to come out and which basically
means it's a game that doesn't quite
work and you can actually go over to
Slytherin I think it's slytherin.com
um if you check the gateworld story it's
on there
um and you can actually request the beta
version and you can get like put on the
waiting list to play it first sort of
thing
um I'm gonna do it
so yeah I think
I dunk game a lot I'm not being I won't
lie we're gonna have to get map to do
this
um but
um it's a Stargate game
so I will be playing it and I gotta give
it a go but also I will be playing it
because if we get this game before an
announcement of a movie which I don't
think we will I think they'll they will
I think this game will get released just
after the announcement so if we get an
announcement date for this game because
we still haven't got one
um then be very interested a couple of
weeks before that because it might mean
that they're going to announce because
you think about it this game comes out
if it comes out after the move is
released the movie's announced that'll
get a load more interesting and get a
load more sales so it's money money and
Amazon like money we all like money so
um yeah I I think that's that's going to
be very interesting to see
it's that whole thing about trying to
have a multi-platform franchise though
that Amazon and I you know I was talking
to you guys about this
18 months ago that they were talking
about doing this multi thing so it'll be
TV series movies games Comics we're
going to see all of this stuff again and
they really want to to you know have the
Stargate franchise in as many different
ways as you can so
I don't you know I I think that's going
to be really exciting
um I Don't Dance damn it
I'll dance with my wife
bring back the evil Asgard I think
that's an interesting story I did I
think the Asgard coming back could be
good and I think the Asgard coming back
could be a way because one of the big
problems we've got with Stargate now is
they're too advanced they've got the
Asgard core
and that's a problem if you bring back
the evil Asgard that's what it's because
those they asked God that were not very
nice corn and they want the core sort of
thing and they want
I think and they actually almost like
blame us
for the loss of the Asgard I I think
that could be that could be interesting
storyline and interesting ways of going
um
I don't know who you've offended but be
more careful
I don't know if it makes I don't know
what will happen there
um evil dancing Asgard
League
of the four races which is your favorite
oh it's a good question guys get in
we're getting this one
um
I think
I think it might be the Knocks
they didn't make any sense to Knox
and that's kind of why I like them
the tree hugging hippies but then
they've got massive floating cities
some are quite big like paradoxes
they're going on
the feelings are the most interesting
they're the ones that most interest me
because we don't we know barely anything
about them
and I still think they're going to be
the best if if you want a good villain
for the new series make it the feelings
because we know nothing about them
they're complete mystery
um so that we could we could do anything
with that
um
so yeah but I always really like the
Knocks
just
Armin schimmerman played one of them as
well and I like him give a cork going so
but guys get to comments what do you
think
um
he's about 50 DVDs
about that anyway yeah no that's not
fair David the problem is with Stargate
universities it's really a mixed bag
that people either love or hate it there
are some people and a lot of people out
there that genuinely believe Stargate
Universe is the best iteration of
Stargate I don't agree with them but
they genuinely do
it would do well but the main thing is
as well a lot of just hardcore Gators
we'll watch the SGU movie because even
if you didn't like Stargate Universe if
you're a gator it must niggle you a
little bit that that story never got
ended but that story is still just there
they're just floating through space
like it most niggly if you you know if
you didn't like Stargate Atlantis you
still want the story to be concluded
because
it's just it's just left there dangling
and we want it I want it sorted and but
I think it'll it'll do really well
um
evil Asgard Branch would be excellent
for a new big bad yeah let's do that uh
on April 1st though that was a joke
[Music]
um
honest pays dividends you stated didn't
make sense as general statement on the
plot to show plot but then it did you
reveal after extensive questioning it
feels good to find any reason to talk
down about the show
custom arguments be nice
um
yeah having some new content to drop
just as a right strike end would make a
hell of a lot of hype that that's why I
think maybe maybe that that
Stargate Universe
um
story has some Merit to it maybe
I just I just find it hard to believe
that they'll have got away with it
without anyone knowing but the thing is
I know I wouldn't have known if they
didn't Stargate Universe movie I am
absolutely certain I'd have heard
nothing about it even though we did hit
little bits we heard that maybe they
were talking to Robert Carlisle and we
heard we did hear some stuff about
Executives talking about SGU
um but it's being made by Warner
Brothers
I haven't got any sources of water but
this I just haven't
I've got one person that worked at
Warner Brothers about six months and
then now they work over at Universal
um so I don't know anybody that looks at
Warner Brothers and obviously because
it's animated movie potentially they're
locked in a room there's no
unless somebody that's actually doing it
talks it's not going to get out
so that's the one thing I have to think
about because if they would if it was
true which I don't know the only people
are going to know are the people
animating it that maybe the people did
the voices but they'll have to sign ndas
um and
you know anybody else wouldn't know if
if they didn't bring David blue back
saying Eli isn't in it for whatever
reason if they've done this or they've
used an active voice Eli because of
issues then baby blue one huh anything
about it and he says oh maybe I'm out of
the loop but he's commented on this on
Twitter maybe I'm out of the loop
there isn't a link for you to be in so
nobody would know nobody knew about the
Babylon 5 movie until JMS dropped it and
it was already finished it was done
so
yeah it would create a massive people
would go nuts
um
popcorn power like the ones that
kidnapped yeah
has got some feelings Coalition is the
new Big Bad why not
I've obviously missed something and they
think because everyone keeps putting one
why
I don't know what's going on there
um
full circle there's a spiritual
successor for the gold out of a survival
necessity that's a good that's that's
pretty good actually
that they are dying the ones that are
left to dying so
um yeah why not
um the profitability of a movie seems
much less than just a series to
something like this but I don't know
um
the profitability of the movie is a risk
and there are still some Asgard knocking
around
um in the Pegasus Galaxy and things so
there are still some and we don't know
that there could be a pocket of Asgard
someone that we don't know about so I
don't think we can say they're extinct
we know the main civilization went
extinct
um so the profit is removed seems much
less yeah yeah I I think that we've
we've said this low something the the
the movie seems like a risk to us
um the pop cast Brothers have talked to
me about this they just think it's
mental when we when we first started
talking about a movie and before
Christmas
um I I got loads of comments going
that's nuts I'm not gonna do that that's
stupid and I got called a liar as I
always do and then there it looks and
then look
laughs on laughing
um but even I'm I'm thinking I don't
want to move it first
I want a TV series I asked you guys I
put a poll on 90 of you said you want a
TV series and also the other thing is
from a cost benefit point of view
it's it's mad
um if they want to bring like at the end
of the day if they do a 10 episode
series for 100 million
and they put that on MGM plus I'm hoping
they don't but if they put out an MGM
Plus
MGM plus would grow very rapidly
because people would have to subscribe
to it they'd have to
all of us would have to subscribe to we
wouldn't want to but we would
um if they put an Amazon Prime even that
will do very well for Amazon Prime but
they're not as bother about Amazon Prime
because Amazon Prime is already the
second biggest streaming series
if they put it on freebie because they
want to push free they people will watch
it and they get advertisement revenue
and that will grow the free v
um brand because Stargate is a brand
that people will go after they will go
and find it this is what streamer
Services love they love TV shows that
people come and find they want a popular
TV show yeah but they if they can get a
TV show that's got an audience of like
maybe 10 million
but they're like obsessed 10 million
they love that show and if they're going
to show this like got 50 million people
but they flipping and out of it they
must have bothered they would rather
have the 10 million obsessed fans so
that is why Stargate is
as exciting for Amazon as it is because
they know the fans will follow it
a movie
if it
if it goes under if it doesn't do very
well it could kill the franchise really
quickly and that's what terrifies me
um
so yeah
popcorn power
They're All Dead see the episode boom
they're not all that and we saw that
their main Planet die we don't know if
there are other colonies with asgardon
we don't know there could be a Starship
with a bunch of asgards sat on for all
we know we don't know
um we did see colonies outside and we
did see us guarding the Pegasus Galaxy
so we don't know that they're all dead
so that's just we just don't
um
hard reboot so on the live video I
talked about last week we did talk about
how a hard reboot is still a possibility
I do think
if they do a hard reboot and they do a
hard reboot well
um we want my we'll moan at first
we won't like it
um but then if it's good
the word of mouth
Gators will come to it and in five years
further down the line we won't care
um but it better be really really good
if they do a hard reboot it that show
would have to be brilliant there's no
hiding from it because the Gators will
go nuts if it's not really really good
um
you know
it would just be such a risk there's not
long enough gone by between ronaldinh
Moore's Battlestar Galactica had like
what 30 years
more of the early 80s and then
Battlestar Galactic came out
late 90s early 90s wasn't it something
like that
um so
you know there was a big there was a
pretty big gap
um we've only had 12 years 15 years 12
years since um SGU ended but also the
other thing is that that bastard
Galactica was very much set in its time
so it was an 80s TV show it was wasn't
the most expensive show in the world
it was very dated
um you knew it was a late 70s early 80s
TV show
um sg1 isn't like that you saw what else
you want now it still looks great you
know there's no there's no um
change on that one so you know it's not
a dated TV show so that's another reason
why a hard reboot would be very
difficult
um
yeah I think yeah I agree with you
Andrew I think we will get a mix of all
three I'm gonna try and catch up
um
like Star Wars yeah
any idea we're gonna cash your zpms from
um Radio Shack
pretty short
um
humanized wraith travel back in time
become a myth of the vampires
sleeping Through the Ages popping up
here and there and they are sparkly
um
we did defeat the all right though
they're gone we won
um that was one of the problems with sg1
towards the end there wasn't it we
became gods
um I think we could defeat the race then
we could defeat their accusing like
biological weapons or something we could
defeat The Wraith
so
I think there are ways we do need to
know how to Todd
um
Buffy the race
um I I love the actor that played Target
and then he went on to appear in the um
in sanctuaries while the nini's IPS and
low
yeah enemy of the gate was astonishingly
good episode
um I just think
with The Wraith we always go on about
SGU because it was such a
a hammer nail the way it ended and
they're just like I said they just float
up in space we can go back and get them
but I think it's just as bad the way SGA
ended and I haven't talked about enough
on this channel at all but SGA we got
swizzed when SGA got canceled it should
never have got canceled
um it should have carried on for at
least another two seasons or do the
movie you know but I mean that it was
just a Calamity of Errors MGM couldn't
afford it MGM desperately wanted
something new and they couldn't do both
that and SGU Brad Ryan stuff had this
idea that they wanted to push
um and and they wanted to do something
different like I get it
um and so they made a decision a
management level and they went let's get
rid of SGA and let's have SGU mistake
and it killed the franchise
um
but
I forgot what I was saying
so there we go I forgot where I was
where I was going with it
um
so yeah I think we need to talk more
about SGA
because it was us losing
SGA was I think just as bad as the way
SGU ended and we need to have an answer
to it
um yeah let's let's do the extreme movie
let's do the extreme comedy series I
want to do it I want to do it let's just
go down to the bottom
um
Todd is an ambassador
well now that humans are on Godlike
level
zero zero one well now that humans are
on a Godlike level other who once
ignored us now we're looking in our
direction as worrying their eyes
I think I know when you're going there
was your show and that that I that was
my idea with when I said that like the
um
or an element of The furlings Returned
I basically said that there was a part
of the feelings that got because the
feelings were kept getting attacked and
a lot of cities getting wiped out
particularly by the Gold World we saw
that in that like suicide plant episode
I forgot the name of the episode
um that was that was an attack by the
gold against a furling colony so I
actually argued that right so the
furlings then after being attacked
repeatedly he decided to try to wipe the
gold walled out or an element of them
did
and there was that element that they
were they were imprisoned they I in my
idea they I did this series ages ago now
you can go back and look at it it's on
one of the playlists
um and so these feelings are actually
trapped within the Stargate so they were
basically sent to another dimension
through a star game
um and the asgards were The Gatekeepers
so they were the ones that were
protecting and stopping this feeling
sect or whatever from coming back
um because the other four races decided
actually we can't Wipe Out the gold it's
not nice to wipe out in the time race
you know
um killing race is bad
so
these feelings now the Asgard had gone
the feelings have been able to return
these bad feelings as it were well not
really bad they were just attacked and
then wanted Revenge sort of thing so
then those feelings have decided
basically that they should be in charge
they've been imprisoned for centuries
and they're just like we're gonna take
over sort of thing and that was my idea
for how that could that would be the
interesting storyline and again we'd get
nice to see a slow burn because they
even though they'd be technologically
advanced
they wouldn't they'd have to build
colonies they'd have to build ships and
it would take them a while to actually
threaten us
um so that gives you the opportunity
but then you can build up towards a big
battle sort of thing um which could be a
movie so I argue that you do four or
five seasons building up and then you do
the movie that's you know like Bill Bill
over that time I'm sorry it was a cool
idea
um SGA Legacy
yeah
we do need an end mem now so we do need
an end to SGA we need something to tell
us more about what
um happen there
um yeah
another reason why we didn't get the SGA
movie though was because
there was an element of
um they were doing these direct DVD
movies
and they just found the wrong timing the
the people stop buying the goodies you
know the the the retail Market just fell
out it felt like that out to us but the
problem was they were a bit too early
for sort of digital releases
so they fell in a really crappy Middle
Ground where they couldn't sell the DVDs
but they weren't actually doing
streaming releases yet so
they should just go to Netflix if I
don't think it's going to Netflix and go
you know what we've got a couple of
Stargate movies you want to buy them and
Netflix probably would have done back
then
um
yeah we still share in the future where
Atlanta's dessert deserted and the rain
for dead according to the hollow Rodney
yeah we did
would love to see that more no comedy
series come on people I so I had this
idea that there would be a Stargate
extreme a wormhole extreme comedy
animated series
and many of you hate that idea
I just think you're not I just think you
need to open up your mind to that one a
little bit and consider the
possibilities because you could give
those creators a completely blank canvas
I love the comedy series of um lower
decks I personally love it I hate that
it's in Canon so what happens in that
series affects you the series it annoys
me because then then that takes away
from the comedy a bit you're like that's
just silly because it's not real
something but it is real apparently
because it's in universe
so you do Wormhole extreme Animated
Series where it's it's Stargate still
but it's not you can have a completely
blank canvas you can do whatever the
hell you want with it you can make it
funny
but the comedy stands up because it's
not in universe
and you can even have characters coming
over from Stargate and stuff and just
having like little crossover things and
stuff because it's not in Universe it's
fun
um so a comedy animated series could
work but that would have to be years
down the line
this is it if the movie is successful if
two or three series are then successful
that's got to be stargate's doing very
very well thank you very much
now we can experimental it and be a bit
busy so we can play with it a little bit
it's not the sort of thing that can come
in the first couple years it's got to be
like five years down the line if
everything else works it's really
successful
um
Pegasus Galaxy is still some stories to
tell I think sep um sepi I think you're
right
um I think any new series has got to
cross
galaxies because it'll just only make it
just makes sense
um
um yeah why not so
we've been talking a little while
or Joseph milosi once posted a notepad
sheet of the preliminary story arcs and
episodes names for season six and it
looked like it would have been great
face purple crank and he also has we we
know a lot of what the movie would look
like and that again would have been
incredible
um I don't remember much about Infinity
I you know what I watched it but I can't
remember anything about it
um
sga's cancellation was unrelated to SGU
being made that was a myth spread by the
hate campaign due to misunderstanding on
how the initial press release it was not
either or
it was
um so there's two different things on
that on one respect
Brad Wright
wanted to do SGU and that's just that's
a that's a fact they wanted to do
something different they felt it was
um they felt they would just done as
much an sg1 and SGA is needed to do and
they were sort of running out of ideas a
little bit
but MGM were going through some massive
financial problems and sci-fi were not
willing to pay for both seasons
so MGM were pushing for SGU they thought
it was they wanted to relaunch something
there was most definitely an either or
it wasn't that that's not hate it's just
the reality of mgm's financial situation
at the time and the Sci-Fi Network's
financial situation at the time
um they they didn't there wasn't a
demand for both
the way it was released that one was
canceled the other ones then then SGU
got announced made it look like
we've got rid of SGA to make way for SGU
and that I I know what you mean in that
that didn't look good and it was badly
handled and actually caused a lot of
hate towards SGU
but there was a financial reality
involved and yes it should have been
handled much better if ideally I think
if they'd have got one more season of
SGA at the very least
um my pants just got delivered to my
Amazon delivery
um so um I bought some new boxes what
you can do
um but there was there was a fans for
reality that they just couldn't afford
both it's just that's just the way it is
um
so guys I only wanted to talk for about
an hour so we'll I'm just going to whip
down to the bottom make sure there's
anything else I wanted to talk about
before we we talked about the SGU rumors
hell they make sense but they're
unlikely come on let's be honest it's
just seem likely the timekeepers game
being delayed it was a big reason
because Amazon wanted it to be delayed
um and yeah the podcast Brothers video
was really interesting it like I said
agreed with most of the things we talked
about
um
and yeah it was it was as simple as that
so
yeah the at some point Joe Flanagan has
tried to buy Stargate he did
he did that was true mgm's Bank on
stream Sapphire going down is more to
blame for SGA and SGU cancellations
yeah there's simply a financial thing
um
yeah that was Battlestar Galactica it
was winning loads of awards and there
was an element and I think Joe
Flanagan's 100 right on that there was
an element I don't think Brad writing
stuff talked about this I think Brad
Wright particularly wanted to do he felt
like we'd become god-like and there was
just no threat there anymore so he
wanted to do something a bit different
where there was risking and there was
threat
um I think the executives were looking
about our Glacier and going can you do
something like that
and Brad Wentworth yeah okay and they've
they copied Battlestar Galactica
um
I I don't think that's true but I think
he did buy bits of it
um so I think that's true SGA was the
best sci-fi had at the time it was about
a Millie miles it was the best show they
had the best characters the best thing
it was just it was just a phenomenally
good series
um it was everything it was everything
we had with sg1 in a different setting
and they got I thought they got it
absolutely perfect to be honest
sci-fi Side Track sister aliens are real
they are
Scythe I think oh yeah guys go over and
my other videos just just gone down now
it's just literally aired now premiering
right now so right guys I am going to
say a lovely good evening I'm going to
start doing these live videos a little
bit more often
um give you the opportunity to throw in
your opinion just me so you know that
you're you know if I'm if Mia Harris are
here or Mia Mata here then it ends up
being a conversation between us I want
you guys
um to have way more opinion
um and no no they're not
let's be honest aliens are we're not the
only life in the universe this is let's
put a pin in that the only so in fact
the question about whether alien life in
the universe is really is not a question
there was definitely alien life the only
question is are they coming here and
visiting and ain't only probing us
that is where I'm not so sure
um but alien life does 100 exist
um
we should do a stream on why the Sci-Fi
channel went crashing down and became
the reality TV movie Sharknado Channel
we all know love didn't love today
sci-fi is just one of those genres that
go as Ebbs and flows it has popularity
and popularity and they kept making
loads of sci-fi shows
with two smaller budget and it just
didn't work and so yeah sci-fi struggled
but then sci-fi's coming back at the
moment so
um yeah so anyway guys
um I don't want to test one so honestly
posted ones I don't disagree with the
brother sg1 SGA at that point we're
running stagnant but it's clear SGA was
the favorite of the three Brad Wright's
series since has developed that SGU
style further yeah
yeah
I'd be very disciplined to the only life
form to evolve this that I think
there'll be life genuinely I think
there'll be life in our
um solar system
it just won't be intelligent it'll be
bacterial and things like that
um I think our first contact with age in
life will be we step off this planet we
step in something slimy we're always all
sticky
and it'll actually be a bacterial
some sort of you know life
um intelligent life I think is going to
be way rare it's going to be so freaking
rare because I mean everything has to be
very specific this has to be a long list
of very happy coincidences
um for intelligent life to evolve but I
actually think the universe will be full
of life
intelligent that we can talk to maybe
not so much
um that's why they don't want Brad right
involved because it would be like SGU it
would be like yes do you like and they
would want an SGA bring way more people
that I don't think that is why
um to be honest
um Chronos I think
um the reason is
less thought through than that they just
want New Blood
and they want a new team
they I don't think it's it's not that
they don't want Brad I don't think the
thought of having Brothers even come
across
I say that
I don't know this for certain but I do
know that Amazon weren't massively happy
with MGM when they went back to Brad and
that when Brad was doing those scripts
just before kovid Amazon kept critiquing
them and kept saying they weren't they
this is what we want this is not what we
wanted and they kept being
um a bit of an ass and they were the
ones that were going to bike the show so
Amazon didn't want Brad even then they
wanted a different team involved they
wanted to go a different direction
um the one thing I kept hearing was that
I think Brad was trying to write a show
for MGM budget and again he I think he
disagrees with this guy I've sort of
mentioned to him and he disagrees with
this but what I heard at the time was
and again it's just a rumor was what I'd
heard was that Amazon kept saying go
bigger go bigger go bigger do more you
can do more we want something bigger and
um and that's that's and you can always
hear an executive of the big cigarette
I'll do it bigger bigger
um and they're just going again what do
you mean you know like not being able to
say and got bigger
um
so that is a thing but I think maybe
Brad was right into an MGM budget and
they didn't realize they had an Amazon
budget
Maybe
um
so yeah
first I've encounter was something we
step on
yeah but guys thank you so so much
um I think that's been really
interesting I'm gonna try to do this as
much as possible I can in the future
um I'd say I want your opinions I want
to be able to talk to you and we're
going to do that
I'm now going to go because my throat
hurts
um how big is big enough for Amazon
let's set it up I'm pretty big with that
don't mean good but they went pretty big
with that
um so yeah
brings the powers massively big
thank you my nails thank you Carrie
thank you everybody else and bring back
the machine that was my original Channel
nobody watched it Andrew you would be it
was only me and you so nobody wants to
and to be honest honestly but this is my
last bit I'm going right
when you look into so many Mysteries and
UFO stories and things like this and you
actually look at it with a critical mind
you realize that a lot of them
are just bull there's there's all or
there's always boring explanations for
them and so many times I did these
talking about these Mysteries and when I
looked into it I was just disappointed
in the matter
that's not this is this is nothing this
isn't real you know a lot of your phone
counters
they're not UFOs 95 of it's just not and
but there are some Mysteries there's
some genuine Mysteries out there but not
enough and and I just got
deflated by it I just stopped believing
in all these things that I'd wanted to
think and I've always said I'm not
necessarily a tin foil wearing hat guy I
don't necessarily believe a lot of these
conspiracies but I like the story and it
was ruining the story for me so I had to
stop doing it right I will see you all
tomorrow guys we will be talking aliens
tomorrow actually so it will be like the
machine my old Channel tomorrow but we
are also talking some
um top 10 really interesting
um sci-fi shows as well that we want to
have chat about the top 10 shows from
the uh the naughties early naughties
we're gonna have chat about so
have a good one I will see you tomorrow
at the same bat Time same bat Channel
and um we will be have the whole gang
together see you then thanks everybody
foreign
[Music]